well first and foremost this is the bad
place i would say congrats
congrats on nine perfect strangers this
show is
incredible um but first of all
hard-hitting journalist question here i
don't know if you read youtube comments
or not but everyone is obsessed with the
facial hair in this
so you are you are now clean shaven was
it hard to get rid of that facial hair
or was it just like let's do this
i'll be honest yeah not at all man um i
think uh maintaining i mean i wish i
mean maybe if it got to like what you
have right now with the beard and the
whole
you know connecting to the sideburns i
maybe i'd consider keeping it but i
can't i can i can get maybe to like
50
of what you have
that's everyone's problem though they
give up too soon they give up too soon
i mean if i if i want to get to that i
think it might be like it might be 20
years down the road to be honest but
um yeah it's uh i i had no problem
taking it off it's uh it's one thing
less that i have to worry about
there you go well nobody's gonna have to
worry about loving nine perfect
strangers this show is incredible i mean
this cast is just completely stacked
nicole kidman is absolutely probably my
favorite actress in the world um melissa
mccarthy hilarious like there are so
many incredible people on this series
were you just like oh my gosh i cannot
believe i am a part of this show
absolutely i was like did you guys get
the wrong person like
you know there are other people out
there right
um yeah i mean i
from from the jump like from um
getting word that i'll be on board to
flying down australia
um coming off the airport to being on
set um like it's i was i always had to
pinch myself
that i was around such
amazing people first of all human beings
but also such professional actors
yeah absolutely
yeah it was huge
yeah absolutely like i said nicole is
one of my absolute favorites and i
always wonder she is so fantastically
creepy in this
like i'm curious if she stayed in like
creep mode throughout the entire shoot
or did she kind of like once they said
cut she would go back to being nicole
kidman who is lovely or did she stay in
that creepy manner
great question um so
uh because i worked with nicole
you know like we had a good amount of
scenes together and yeah we worked
pretty close um
uh yeah like i she doesn't stay in it
the whole time
but there are definitely moments
where i did not know if i was dealing
with masha or nicole like
you know like before i take so like
we would start talking about something
and it would take me you know maybe a
good two three seconds before i was like
oh okay this is who i'm talking to so i
had to be weary of that
and to be honest and this was funny to
me
um
other cast members
not until like the end of of the filming
process did they really get to you know
experience the actual nicole they're
like oh this is this is
because
um yeah i know she would definitely stay
in it for a good amount of time
but luckily because we had a lot of work
to get we had a lot of time together
there were moments where i was able to
talk to
the australian nicole kidman um who's
very sweet and kind
she is very sweet and kind all right for
people who don't know i was lucky enough
to see this series already for people
who don't know tell me who your
character is and how they fit into this
wellness retreat
okay um so my character uh is yao i play
yao who is one of the staff at
tranquilom and you could say that he's
like the
right hand man um
um to to for for uh manchester's
right-hand man who was played played by
nicole kidman and
uh there's a trio so there's there's
mantra there's delilah and there's yao
and yao within that trio acts as kind of
the moral compass um the kind of the
straight arrow in terms of trying to
to get
um
the
the
uh to trying to get tranquillium and
their principles going basically
but in a still grounded and more um
uh genuine manner where as the other
uh trio have their own kind of
intentions and and thoughts
it is a wonderfully dark show we don't
want to spoil anything let me ask you
this uh after
taking part in this series would you
attend a wellness retreat let's say that
like gwyneth paltrow who has like these
goop retreats yeah would you if she
extended an invite would you go to the
wellness retreat
oh man
100
that is i am this that sucker yeah i i
hate to admit it but
i am that guy that would that would try
all these things i don't know if it's
like
i don't know being an actor and needing
needing some like support
as as to or like my attending to my ego
and whatnot but i will be that guy
like take my money if if it has anything
to do with health and wellness and and
trying to find enlightenment
that is me uh final question everyone is
so excited for top gun maverick you are
a part of that you are you are killing
it manny like this is incredible
um so many people are excited for this
we love to see people from canada
succeed you are fantastic what can you
tell us about the film and how excited
are you for people to see this because
people are waiting and waiting and i'm
so excited myself
i i i i can't wait i think but there has
been a lot of waiting um like again 30
years since the first one i think that's
when i was born
um
and like we filmed that
i think two years ago and it's been
delayed delayed constantly so a lot of
people been waiting for this and i just
you know want to reiterate that there's
been a lot of waiting because tom and
the team behind the whole team have been
wanting to put out a product that
is so thrilling and so exciting and i
think they've definitely accomplished
that so i'm yeah i'm stoked for people
to see it
see it in theaters uh definitely over
and over again
um yeah it's it's gonna be a ride for
sure
you